samedi nous sommes à présent plus âgés
tout
pour les honore cette semaine chaque
matin c'est suivi de mathématiques sept
élèves de ce2 est en stage eureka au
centre alfred de vigny son professeur
est là pour l'accompagner identifier ses
difficultés par fame little italy mal
puisqu'ils achats fatah pesci trop etc
et à chaque fois chine il donc s'il a du
temps ça serait ou je ne sais pas au
début c'est pas la fin ça serait
peut-être dans quelle période de temps
catherine b d'och donnent de la méthode
au centre alfred de vigny le travail se
fait en petit groupe jusqu'à cinq
enfants je fais toujours un petit un
petit diagnostic avec eux je demande de
voir les contrôles les cahiers de façon
à intervenir là où les besoins bien sûr
que l'on en tête dans chaque année de
ces sois primaire au collège il y a des
notions à avoir plus importantes et des
caps et des compétences à acquérir tout
va mieux du compromis qui prend
tranquillement
tommy ton le centre-ville chinois
propose aussi un suivi de ses élèves
tout au long de l'année un suivi
hebdomadaire pour asseoir des progrès